[Music]
all right good morning my name is Nikhil
animus and I'm the NDP candidate for
Hamilton East Stoney Creek I want to
begin this morning by acknowledging that
we were on the traditional territories
the Amish now be at a hardness Shoni
First Nations I also want to acknowledge
my colleagues Scott Duvall candidate for
Hamilton Mountain Yosef Malik candidate
for Hamilton West and caster Dundas and
Matty Greene candidate for Hamilton
Center
I'm at the doorstep every day listening
to stories about people who are having
difficulties struggling with the high
cost of Pharma care and dental care
people like Gina Angeloni this is her
daughter Gwen
I also hear a lot of frustration about
politicians who say the right things but
don't do them I'm here to tell you that
jug meat sing is different he's not only
here in Hamilton
talking about how to make things better
he's doing that across the country he is
the only leader willing to take on the
rich and well-connected he is the only
leader willing to stand up to powerful
Insider of lobbyists and therefore he is
the only leader truly on your side
that's why I am so proud to be running
under his leadership in this election so
please welcome the leader of the New
Democratic Party of Canada junk meat
sing thanks so much thank you so thanks
to all our amazing candidates are being
here and they said
to the Dean for hosting us again in your
lovely restaurant we wanted to talk
about what what life is like right now
that for small businesses we can't
afford the coverage that they would love
to have to give to their staff and what
it means not having that coverage and
what that's like
so go get out but maybe have a bit of a
chat and talk about what that's like
maybe maybe you can tell us a little bit
about what it's I guess as an owner and
you you know you know it's something you
want to do you'd love to have that
coverage it's incredibly expensive tell
me a little bit about it well certainly
when you have employees around six seven
employees and for small business whereas
a lot of factors to record your business
struggling on day to day expenses and to
add on an additional cost example like
something like dental care it becomes a
really very very high it's only so as a
matter of fact the employees are
deprived off and they want to go as a
matter of fact and look at it and they
are hesitant because they're on foot a
small visit at the same time cannot
afford to cover that's what the expenses
are so I think absolutely they will be
delighted and motivated
more productive in government and bigger
leadership offers that than free I think
they would be more productive at work as
well I mean since you see benefit for
you for your time oh honey absolutely
really come [ __ ] you have motivated
employees you have more production
that's right that's a point maybe you
can tell us a little bit about what it's
like for any folks working we were
talking about it before when you think
about going to the dentist do you go
right away or do you say help me put it
off too expensive this is a funny sound
wait well the cheaper will save when you
make it talked about yeah
anyone else you want to add maybe you
when you think about your family and
going to the dentist and or maybe
getting medication what that's what that
all I like any single visit if you think
about it to a dentist it's not cheap
like nothing is covered medicines not
covered right one single visit that's
just approximate idea five thousand
dollars that's my ID right if you had
treatment on top that's a root canal
therapy that's $10,000 each
just for one procedure done if that was
covered you could take all that
financials invested somewhere else
be more productive right incredibly
expensive
I met families recently never talked
about receding gums they were brushing
the teeth they're doing everything they
needed but they hadn't gone in to a
dentist and then their teeth were the
gums are receding and it cost thousands
and thousands of dollars simply cannot
afford it 50 Kent like I'm an
international student right so for me
it's easier for me to go back home and
get it done get the procedure done but
it's just not even half the price all
right it's not covered there but it's
half the price less than that even if it
makes better sense so but it's the same
thing you spend that much on a ticket
and go back so it adds up right so I'd
rather have it here of course they must
have you better and for you what do you
think about the cost of medication or
and it started maybe maybe that stories
you said that you've heard at the
doorsteps
so what we're in door is there it's very
very welcome news hearing from a lot of
people that lost their jobs in Sears or
when Stella went into bankruptcy that
there was cut off automatically they had
some coverage so a lot of people because
of plant closures or whatever they used
to have benefits now they going any
longer right and they're very very
worried about the world we're heading in
the future because of the high cost of
its own I'm here we're at the door it's
very welcome news and people appreciate
that Jim let's start arresting you want
to at it certainly I mean obviously an
open Center has one of the lowest median
household incomes in the country it's
forty-three thousand dollars a household
and I think about when I'm on the doors
talking to people the cost of poverty
I'm thinking about the dignity of having
a nice smile you know and for people who
are living in deep poverty who aren't
able to access proper dental care or
seeing it through the seniors we're
seeing it with with families and we're
also seeing it particularly with with
young children it's a startling but I
could also share that as a former
entrepreneur a small business owner
myself I actually wasn't covered for ten
years I didn't have dental coverage
until I became a city councilor and
throughout this campaign we're
constantly talking to people sharing
that we just want for others what we
want for ourselves and that's the
dignity of a good smile and and having
those you know those programs and
policies in place to be able to take
care of our families I still a sense if
we just bring Gina before you go to you
sir Gina tell me you talked about the
cost of medication and how that's like
really big burden
type one diabetics my whole life I've
been covered under my mom and dad when I
was a kid and then when I was in college
you have student benefit packages but
once your